do you think Sal if we showed him the  word statistician Oh written down you  think you could say it no we can't say  that but that's a sporting event  statistician yeah but it's a tough word  for even people who know what it is to  say just a statistician what we got it  right on what level what go for a  statistician your genius guess what  you'll get your ears checked JD you  believe this guy  telemedicine I'd say two more times now  so we can laugh at you JD is sitting  behind you laughs and I know at you and  it's so funny  and you're struggling with the English  language like you're in a war you're in  the fight of your life with a word say  it again statistician JD telemedicine  statistician oh now say it's now  statistician so JD ain't such a mush  mouth is